more than 30 thousand people are under
evacuation orders in northern california
as a string of destructive wildfires
continues to rage out of control the
caldor fire burning in el dorado county
has burnt more than 62 thousand acres it
is zero percent contained that's zero
jonathan bigliotti is near the fires in
pollock pines
gail the caldorfire is producing more
smoke than flame this morning as it
burns in largely remote areas there are
thousands of crews fighting several
fires here in northern california but
with more than a dozen fires burning
across the state it's not nearly enough
gusty winds dry conditions and record
drought are making for dangerous fire
weather in northern california this is
all that's left of grizzly flats after
the caldor fire tore through the area
the small town lost a post office and
dozens of homes including one that
belonged to derrick shaves it was a
beautiful
close small vibrant community
it's nothing now all that remains of
walter tyler elementary is a sign and a
charred playground the school burning to
the ground on what was supposed to be
back to school night it is incredibly
devastating because it's such a loss of
something that is so near and dear to so
many people
and not just a building
there is only one long and narrow road
into grizzly flats and what's incredible
tonight it appears everyone managed to
make it out of this destruction alive
these survivors now join a growing group
of people across the state who have no
home
no town to return to
as the wildfires intensify officials are
stressing the impact of climate change
our climate driven conditions are
altering the environment and are making
these fires move faster and make them
more complex and ultimately more
dangerous take the dixie fire officials
believe the massive blaze is the first
ever to burn clear across the sierra
nevada mountains fire has been burning
for
approximately 30 35 days it is
exceedingly resistant to control
and even the latest in technology can't
keep up cal fire recently spent hundreds
of millions of dollars on new
helicopters capable of performing tricky
nighttime aerial drops they were
grounded overnight because of the thick
smoke
anthony jonathan thank you burning for
35 days